so what does that look like to you to me
especially having worked in education
for such a long time
and then meeting 11 year olds who have
absolutely no idea what sex is how it
works what a relationship is what is a
healthy and a non-healthy relationship
i believe that if more
if it was seen as less taboo in society
and more parents in the household would
discuss in sex with their children from
a young age discussing childbirth where
children come from how are children made
and the biology of it and the love side
of it yeah if that was given to children
from a young age i guess the curiosity
for all this hardcore stuff
wouldn't be so
shocking yeah i i don't is there any
evidence that really suggests that
exposing kids to sex ed and corn earlier
results in promiscuity or something and
less promiscuity
because from what i've seen it's really
the opposite because after they
introduced sex out in school the
opposite result happened yeah
but that's school yeah but i do think i
do think parents should
because otherwise your kids are learning
from their peers
so and and they're gonna go i mean you
should be i feel like parents should be
just transparent so it shouldn't it
should be what you said and the love
aspect of it but you should also
you should sort of
you should be in the same line of who
they're likely to be learning from
outside of the household because
whatever you say at home they're going
to rebel against and it's more likely to
be different from whatever necessarily
it depends on the way in which you teach
but yeah but it's also like as a parent
you vet who your kid hangs out with yeah
and you vet with schools they go to we
didn't have sex at my high school we
didn't have a problem with teen
pregnancies we were just
but you can only vet for so long once
they get to 11 yeah you're not really
they're at high school now so your your
contact with the school and the parents
for example is not i mean yeah but you
can home school i don't actually know
what the laws are around homeschooling
but it's pretty easy to come home school
or like go to a smaller school that sort
of thing i personally think the earlier
you
um
introduce it to them the earlier they're
going to be inquisitive to the physical
side of it me personally um i think
many many many many many years ago it
would have been
sex itself would have been very much a
ritual
practice
so it would have been
very sacred et cetera et cetera yeah but
because it's normalized now if you don't
see the actual physical watch you might
see a rendition of it in a music video
people are now saying oh we might as
well introduce it to them because they
see so and so shaking their bum and
kids are doing it then we automatically
associate that movement with sex and
then
it becomes a domino effect yeah me i
wouldn't want my daughters to know about
it until they actually
have uncertain feelings or she begins uh
but you wouldn't know that's the thing
too late do you see one so so
i i think it it should start with the
parents having no boundaries in terms of
open conversation and communication
because if your daughter knows there's
certain things she can't come to you or
or her mom about
it
she's she's gonna go she's just it's
never gonna happen and
if going by what you're saying if you
don't introduce it in the beginning
if you wait until she has those feelings
when she has those feelings she's not
coming to you because you already don't
have that open communication
specifically about sex people feel
embarrassed about sex i think it depends
on the relationship that you have it
doesn't matter so so for example my
sister my little sister i was fine
no i mean so yeah i mean i don't know
what the rule on the exception is but
for example my little sister we raised
her like
to her my brother and i are her her dad
right
so we raised her as best we could right
and she had a ton of respect for us
however when she hit a peak age when
she's going out she's pulling up her
skirt it doesn't matter the relationship
we have at a certain point she's going
to make these decisions for herself so
even if not with everyone but i feel
like even if you do your best at some
point she's gonna yeah they're gonna
they're gonna find out about it yeah
that's that's true but i i need to see
evidence that more exposure to those
sorts of things reduces promiscuity yeah
because i i'm i'm telling you so we'll
wrote a whole book on this yeah and it
has the opposite effect right so when
they introduced sex ed in schools and in
more of the culture promiscuity went up
i'm not down for everyone here do you
think that you would have benefited more
from being taught about sex by your
parents or by your school i think
personally me for like 100
because like i said
actually to be fair i was the first one
of my friends to lose a virginity but of
course you were but yeah
it wasn't my choice
for example had your uncle for example
sat you down yeah once he realized that
you had found his collection
and had an open honest conversation with
you around the safety around the
expectations around the differences in
this and real life relationships etc etc
and then spoke to you about his culture
of his use of it do you not think that
that would have been
foundation laying
for you to not then go
oh so exciting it's so exciting yeah
yeah so i agree yeah so yeah so if it
would alter the course of my my
development in that in that area because
it would have been not normalized but
like if if it's a person i look up to
and
i aspire to be like i'm more likely to
listen to them so even if it won't be
the parent you know
whatever you're talking about as
nonsense i'm going to go listen to my
friends because i want to be like you
everything even if i can relate to your
youth if you bring me down and you tell
me when i was this age i did this to
normalize it even more but whereas as
opposed to taboo and off limits and
things like that if he was to sit you
down and have that conversation about
the birds and the bees and relationships
your only recollection of sex up to that
point is porn so regardless you're going
to go with that corn you're going to go
that way
because you as you said you look up to
him so you're going to imitate what he
does and you're like if you can do it i
can do it that's when you're and it
wasn't a little bit irresponsible though
for him to like yeah yeah 100 yeah so
i'm leaving that around my thing is i
think most adults are ill-equipped to
have this conversation do you think so i
think yeah you're right it takes a
someone that isn't
i don't want to say isn't watching corn
but understands the the problems they've
come with
yeah exactly the repercussions
to have a
mindset to say this is how i can talk to
this child because what you'll find is
if an adult
has a conversation with the child
which is trying to reassure them they
may just be exposing them to
things that they never really needed to
know yeah and it can be really
detrimental to the child's mindset and
the thing is once like you take away a
kid's innocence they can't get that back
and so my mom always tried to keep me as
innocent as possible for as long as she
could and i just i was always really
grateful for that because i had some
friends where like their innocence was
like lost a lot younger and they were
like sleeping around in like i don't
know 14 15 years old and i just grew up
in a family where that was protected and
valued so i don't know why
that's like one of the most valuable
things you have as a kid
do you equate innocence with lack of
knowledge yes yeah of course like if
you're more innocent if you're better
than me
but i mean but also we're trying to find
that fine line because we live in a
society that is quite perverted and
there are children that get taken
advantage of it's that um fine line of
trying to find where you what you're
what you should be telling your children
to protect them right versus what you
should be telling them to just i don't
know
exactly i think that's what i think this
easiest way to do it then is instead of
it being right and wrong yeah
is how you deem corn
healthy for your child or unhealthy
you're asking me just in general like
that all right like for me i've been on
both sides so i've watched corn i've
done those things i now don't do them
because i yeah deem it to be unhealthy i
don't deem it to be
beneficial to me mm-hmm
but you can't control the consumption of
it outside the household of course
there's always going to be external
factors in everything exactly
but would you deem it to be healthy to
introduce them to that and say this is
that so so i wouldn't i
i'm not i wouldn't say i'm an advocate
for introducing it to them ahead of time
because just so they don't find out
outside of the house but i think
i think the most important factor in
affecting how they consume corn or how
they view sex is
your relationship with your child from
the very beginning just in general do
you know what i mean because
because
in my upbringing my aunties one of my
aunties raised my brother and i
and it was like a typical parent
children oh we teach you how to put a
condom on a banana whatever it is let's
laugh about it because it's embarrassing
however when they were away we were
fingering our
our
family
friend like not cousins but let's just
call them family friends yeah family
friends you know i mean
cousins in the same in the same
environment where they've already showed
us how to put a condom in a banana but
that's because we didn't have a
relationship
and it wasn't
whatever you tell me now is you're cool
but eventually i'm going to give in to
my urges and i'm if when she comes
around i'm going to finger her so yeah
you're going to have those urges
regardless of whether they taught you
but that's what i'm that's what i'm
saying but if i had a better
relationship from the beginning not not
a parent and a child relationship just
obviously there's got to be some some
element of that but if i had a better
relationship with with my aunties or my
uncles or my mum or dad
i'm gonna have the urges but it won't be
taboo
to go on chances it won't be it won't be
a dirty thing that i'm waiting to do
after they they're backstage and it will
be normal and it's like okay well you
wanna do you wanna do it in front of
them like like i mean yet
like i just i'm trying to no answer
watch this
look what i learned there's no parent in
their right mind is going to be like yes
bring the hose over
i think it
instead of out on the streets because
i've heard parents
say that they'll
underage drinking they'll be like oh i'd
rather have them do it here than
somewhere else and so parents would
rather have their to a degree i mean i
think drinking but it's another thing
when you can make a child from it no but
that's not it's not that i want to do it
in front of them but i just remember how
filthy we were despite them just doing
the regular
parent thing and being like this is poor
this is what it is i i have i remember
we were like
it was nasty but it was nasty because it
was off limits
that's the only reason it's nasty that's
do you know what i mean like it's it's
interesting because our experience is
like i had a really similar like it was
off limits but i just didn't do it and
i'm like grateful for that yeah
do you think the more it becomes taboo
the more people want to do it yes i
think naturally yeah just human nature i
guess
a special breed but i think she's an
anomaly
i don't know i'm just telling you by
high school we didn't like it wasn't
that it was a wild like that really yeah
and we had chastity speakers every year
oh my gosh
we had no we had no teen pregnancies at
my high school except possibly one but
this girl was crazy i feel like she was
lying for her to like
i never saw a baby
she was like i'm pregnant but there's no
baby yeah
like i'm not gonna speak for her lexi i
hope you're good
name name-dropping as well
i think it comes back to what ish was
saying with regards to parents being
ill-equipped
if a parent is equipped and has
knowledge has a research and there was
more of a
societal norm
that
you did speak to your children about
childbirth and relationships and loving
your partner and
that kind of stuff then and it as it as
the age increases and it becomes more
age-appropriate to then
talk about sex and lovemaking
in that manner
then i don't think it would bring on
more promiscuity can you say you're
equipped to have the conversation i
believe i am if you watch a lot of corn
and if you can't maintain a
a healthy healthy and this is why i
think you can
i don't know because you're so is it
because you're not speaking from
experience on the other side so you know
is corn and isn't that like the blind
leading the blind right no but if it's
not my idea right if i'm if i'm a drug
addict yeah i know i don't want my child
to be a drug addict if i'm obese i know
how i've gotten here and if i can stop
this person from doing that i'm yeah but
i i'm in an ideal position to be like
don't but i wouldn't want an obese
trainer
but you need to be healed
you need to you need to be healed that's
what that's that's that's why i say i
agree
sorry if i set you the task of oh go x
amount of time without it
just to see the flip side then you can
speak from both sides
i've done it then you know if it's
healthy or unhealthy yeah
ultimately it's on here ultimately when
you say done it what's done it
i've gone on the flip side and gone
without how long has it i don't know
months three months has it ever been an
issue for you in your relationships
like
yeah but in in terms of what watching it
or no like effects of watching it the
effect of watching it as she not liked
it
you know as has there been like an issue
with corn in your relationship there's
never been an issue with me watching it
as in like yeah because you like to work
as in my partner not one to me to watch
it but there's been issues in terms of
um being desensitized
to sex because
you know like as i said in the beginning
it's just is it everything i've seen
i would say boring it's just
you train your brain to like what what
you're visually seeing and then if
you're used for example if you used to
only
ejaculating when
the man comes in the woman's face
just simply ejaculate in any regular way
it won't do it for you because that's
what you've trained your brain
to associate how is it not doing it for
you if you're already coming
so it's a different sensation yeah when
it comes no so so psychological so what
i'm saying is if if i'm what if every
time for the last year i've ejaculated
is when the guys come in the face but
i'm having sex just and it's intercourse
me looking at her bum or her body or
whatever won't do it for me because i've
told my brain this does it for me yeah
does that no i understand yeah but i'm
are you still are you not coming yeah
i'm just not i'm just gonna [ __ ] for
hours it's just it's not going to go
anywhere
i mean it can if i force it if that
that's why most guys tend to have a
finishing position yeah
they like
finish the finishing move they have
their finishing move because that's
their one yeah it's that sweet spot in
it yeah well you get the most friction
i'm gonna read some super chats real
quick
i was like just let me do something
other than this
this is why it's called the gray area
folks dad please don't watch this
this is why it's called the gray area
my family doesn't typically watch but my
dad's been hopping on some streams my
family watching more than
yeah i know i i asked my dad i'm like
dad do you watch my show ever and he's
like you think i got time for that it's
like three hours
okay so um
first super chat moose toffee is better
than van dijk
i don't know if they are okay
educating kids on corn breeds curiosity
they can't think of something that they
don't know if you don't want promiscuity
don't educate kids and make them marry
as virgins to the moon so you're telling
me a drag queen story time for kids is a
bad thing damn i was told gender
reassignment surgery for children safe
and normal nathan hamrich talking about
how corn ruins men's expectations while
women could fulfill those desires but
choose not to and women meanwhile have
expectations that men couldn't fulfill
if they wanted to smh
okay seriously yes you got something to
say go ahead
so
are you finished
you're telling me i'm a letter oh okay
you're telling me
that
some ex gymnast that can flip her legs
over her head do all this crazy stuff a
regular woman's supposed to be able to
do that
how you're asking me like i said oh
like
as a i'm an athlete
i can't i can touch my toes but i can't
i can't do a gymnast move how
like it's unrealistic you gonna learn
today
again i've never i've never seen this
stuff so i don't i don't know what's
going on on the side of the internet but
was it lana rhodes it says right here is
the most for like searched corn actress
now
lana
she's on social media now but she
doesn't really look that athletic
you don't you don't have to look
athletic to be flexible you don't have
to be yesterday i'm saying someone
that's she's she's stretching a
her
lot
she's doing some things
trying to have sex with contortionists
that's not well
the the super chat was saying that we
need to live up to the corn like the
corn is way more than that i don't i
don't know what it looks like so i don't
know what i'm living up to okay so we're
living up to boob jobs we're living up
to bbl's we're living up to labia
plastics we're living up to filters
makeup oh no no
no no no that's not women that's on
women yeah that's not
i don't think men